une balance pour mesurer l'évolution du
poids et contrôler la dénutrition un
bracelet d'autonomie équipé d'un système
GPS pour suivre le malade dans ses
déplacements et éviter notamment les
fugues des personnes atteintes
d'Alzheimer la personne s'en va le
système déclenche une alarme locale et
sonore et ensuite on
transmet au système des aides soignants
l'information de la fugue au niveau du
table voici quelquesunes des solutions
mises en place par l'entreprise blue
Lina dont la plateforme est implantée
est en cours un dispositif de bouquet de
service pour garantir le maintien à
domicile des personnes dépendantes salué
par la ministre déléguée aux personnes
âgé là nous avons
l'illustration de piste pour permettre
comme le souhaite tous les Français le
fait de rester à son domicile en
vieillissant nous sommes dans le champ
du mouvement de l'innovation et je dois
dire que je suis extrêmement heureuse en
particulier
du concours entre l'entreprise et les
collectivités territoriales ici qui ont
su se mettre en en cohérence et en
convergence avant une commercialisation
complète comptait 69 € par exemple par
mois pour ce bracelet d'autonomie dont
une prise en charge à hauteur de 40 %.
une expérimentation va être menée auprès
de 1500 foyers couvrant une large zone
entre Versailles Grand Parc jusqu'à
corbeille et sonne un tiers des foyers
seront
cinantinois les personnes sont en cours
de recrutement nous on parle pas de
personne on parle de foyer 1500 foyers
parce que souvent quand on met en place
ce genre de dispositif on permet de
protéger les patients d'assister les
soignants mais aussi d'accompagner les
aidants ce recrutement va se faire par
le biais des communes euh donc des CCS
des clics des Mayas des différentes
structures bien évidemment nous avons en
chef de fil l'IPS l'Institut de
promotion de la santé de Trapp et puis
aussi g handicap voir aucun dispositif
sera opérationnel dès le 2 avril quant
au gouvernement il lancera le 24 avril
prochain la Silver économie une filière
pour réunir tous les métiers liés au
secteur de la perte
d'autonomie